hey guys Happy Thanksgiving and today is
Thursday so that is another dev stream
recap like always but as well as last
week it's gonna be a pretty slow news
day except a few interesting patches
that are going to be coming so let's get
started so first ups one really quick
thing level-3 bots should be appearing
less and less in normal matches to
prevent BOTS from stomping lobbies with
newer players so that's one thing
double xp is also going to be up for
this weekend for all modes and orders so
if you have a new character you want to
play and level that up you should do
that right away as well as there's also
going to be a tribute weekend order
which is play as many matches as
possible as well as an event this
weekend which is also going to be
tribute in all variations of market-town
so feel free to enjoy the tribute mode
while you can
and then lastly they ended it with a Q&A
and some of the more important bits were
there might be some upcoming changes to
salvage they're coming up with ideas on
how to have a spend more Salvage but
there's no news on it at the moment
they're still working on it
another thing is they're also expecting
to have more events like the Halloween
mode appear in the future as well as
different variations of game modes
similar to the skeleton March Dominion
mode which would be crazy to have maybe
there'll be a Christmas one I'm not
entirely sure of course but maybe
there'll be some for Easter and some
other the holidays later later in the
season also to all you warden mains and
possibly night players Ubisoft is aware
of the fact that we want plumes on our
warden and all the night characters so
they are aware of it they haven't made
anything yet but maybe there'll be
plumes in the future so hooray to that
finally
next up the reasoning behind why they
put elimination and skirmish together in
the same playlist like last time back in
season 1 was because of the addition to
tribute mode and they're trying to keep
the player base together and not trying
to split it by adding so many different
playlists to choose from because
remember on top of the game modes they
also have the AI versions I mean not
everybody plays the AI version of the
game mode but still it's also considered
a different playlist so there's tons of
new modes that people can play and
they're trying to group everyone
together and not have extremely long
queue times like if you're trying to
play skirmish they're also working on a
new XP system like a possible XP bonus
that you can maybe buy would steal but
once again that's just my assumption but
they're working on something but they
haven't said anything about it yet time
stamp is also
being readjusted to hopefully prevent
the constant changes in speed of attacks
making it very inconsistent so that's
hopefully being worked on very soon and
then lastly to end they talked about
shaman a lot of people have been crying
nervous about her so they decided to do
a few things with her regarding her and
one of the things they're doing is
fixing her tracking out predators hunger
and mercy and wild cats rage which
should be coming up in the next patch
wild cats rage hit and block recoveries
are being increased from 700
milliseconds to 800 milliseconds shamans
also getting a nerf to her predators
mercy and hunger and wild cats rage as
well making it cost 20 for stamina
instead of 10 Wildcats rage and
swiftness damage is now being reduced
from 25 to now 20 damage and the pounce
is also going to be reduced from 25 to
20 damage as well the range of her
predators hunger is also going to be
reduced from 2 meters down to 1 meter so
she won't be able to jump across a very
long distance to grab an opponent this
time it'll be somewhat realistic these
patches should also be coming out next
week if not the week after they want to
take these nerves very slowly because
they don't want to be nerfing her too
much and then making her unplayable like
other certain characters within the
roster and then lastly to end can say
conquer and also the other low tier
heroes are still getting new moves
coming out but nothing at the moment
they're still waiting for the defensive
meta changes to be released to see if
they actually do need these or if the
defensive meta is pushing them up in the
in the roster of high tier 2 low tier so
once again nothing on that we'll have to
wait until the defensive meditators come
out to get any news on that but this
ended the video like I said it was a
slow news day since they obviously just
released season 4 a couple weeks ago
hopefully next week we're gonna be
getting some more stuff who knows maybe
to be another slow news day but once
again I'll always recap the stuff for
you guys anyway if you did enjoy the
video please be sure to give it a like
subscribe if you're new I cover the news
leaks and discussions about 400 like I
always do my two news videos are gonna
be on screen one of them was a montage I
decided to do for the first time ever so
if you haven't seen that be sure to
check it out and give me your honest
opinion on it really would help me out
and with that guys okay have a great
rest of your day
Happy Thanksgiving and peace out guys